good hire you can tell he hasn't been
going because this is just I don't know
what to expect from CrossFit at all I
don't know much about it I feel like
everything I know about CrossFit is just
things that I've heard from other people
or in the movies I've taken one CrossFit
class before and it was a really hard
workout hard enough that I thought I
would never return I imagine it's going
to be someone towering over me telling
me very loudly that I'm not trying hard
enough because I probably won't be the
energy of everyone working out together
I'm sure helps but I'm not a very
competitive person when it comes to this
sort of thing
that kind of like camaraderie really
puts me off at the end of the day my
goal is to remain alive this might not
be my cup of tea
but we'll find out
the first day was brutal it looked like
a gym for Robocop's it's like really hot
in there I've never sweat so much like
I've done hot yoga and I feel like I've
never been that disgusting before one of
the interesting things about CrossFit is
that every day is a different workout
which is why it's called the workout of
the day you know that it's going to be
Olympic weightlifting combined with high
intensity interval training and that
you're gonna be dead so I've made it one
I'm going to start with 15 wall finish
your wall will cover the rest a minute
to rest when the second minute turn you
start your pull-ups you finish those
have the rest a minute to rest and we're
basically follow that pattern for 20
minutes we did a bunch of wall balls it
was like cruel and unusual punishment so
a wall balls this thing where you just
pick up a big heavy ass ball and you
throw it at a wall over and over like
Sisyphus if anyone ever says hey you
want to do some wall balls just be like
f Gough the Delirium
drink bottle water get coconut water
electrolyte didn't you write here
inspiration I feel like I only sweat
like that in a sauna it was about what I
expected
which is pretty rough I just left like I
don't know if I can ever go back and do
this again I wanna die and I have two
more months of it so
I mean I don't smell like myself I smell
like many people's sweat combined waking
up for class is probably the hardest
part about it in about 20 to 30 minutes
I'm gonna be in a very hot room yelling
and sweating getting get real tired of
waking up early but afterward well look
I'm ready to work I could that can
swallow the world whole right now so I'd
go to CrossFit from 7:00 to 8:00 and
then I'd have from 8:00 to 9:00 to like
rush home get ready and come into work
and so I always looked like a bag of ass
coming into work I heard some bad all
right well this is our midway point I
feel that different I feel like the
workouts have gotten easier and then
more difficult and then easier again
it's just so varied that it doesn't feel
like something you can ever prepare for
it's been a good jumpstart to working
out and after this I can't complain
about any workouts that I ever do all
right well here's to another month
Cheers I don't know like a month in I
couldn't go on a Monday and so I made it
up on Tuesday and Shane wasn't there I
saw Macy's name and time on the board
because she was going to the class right
before me but I never saw Shane's name I
suspected that maybe he was going on a
different day sometimes your schedules a
little crazy and then I went Wednesday
Shane wasn't there yeah I started really
really slipping I was like when is he
going I just straight-up lied to Macy's
face but she got more sleuthy than I did
today I'm going to the Tuesday class I'm
gonna ask the trainer Ethan if he's been
coming for a while I got away with it
last time he's been in has been 821 on
Friday at 7:00 a.m. oh my god he's in so
much trouble so we decided we needed to
punish him we're here to shame Shane
that's the name of the workout today so
we had the two trainers surprise him at
his death
hey Shane we have some visitors for you
I saw the two crossfit instructors walk
in that's not a thing you want to see it
was like waking up and seeing a vampire
in your room yeah we figured that it'd
be fair to kind of bring the work out to
you so we're gonna do a set amount of
burpees and wall balls per day that
we've missed all right
I just believe fully accepted because
here's the thing they thought it was a
punishment but to me I was like great
I've skipped numerous classes I don't
know if the little cheerleader outfit
was necessary he's going to be doing 11
rounds of ten wall balls and then ten
burpees
Shayne make your way to the wall I
didn't mean lean against it you know
watching that punishment was somewhat
satisfying because it was in the middle
of the workday yeah it was funny it was
one of the low points of my life but
once again entirely worth it it's a lot
of fun which I did this every afternoon
he met the challenge head-on however
long it took with good spirits and
that's what it's all about for our last
class we invited some of our coworkers
two of whom are like really big
CrossFitters and then Ryan just because
you know look at it that was the most
brutal workout that we had to do and I
think that that was a great end note
because the three of us felt totally
sick was mostly cool to see Ryan like
struggle through it he looked like he
was gonna throw up a couple times
sweating vodka and to be fair I also
almost threw up and then obviously Kate
and Jordan kicked all of our asses
because somehow they actually love
CrossFit not cut out for cross yeah you
are I think CrossFit is good for anyone
at any skill level to push themselves
past what they think their capabilities
are it was cool to like challenge myself
and see that I was stronger than I
thought I was I can see how it appeals
to a lot of people there's like a great
group mentality
the instructors like Ethan and Mike were
awesome and super supportive so I can
definitely see how people form their
CrossFit gym into the community CrossFit
is fun too like I'm not a person who's
into team sports at all I don't really
like high fives or round of applause but
there was something nice about feeling
accomplished and having someone near you
confirm that you that you've lived
through that workout yeah rock oh you
know it was nice dipping my toe in the
water for a little while it was a good
dip never gonna do it again
you